hey everyone we're back with some of the
wildest Nickelodeon fan theories that
are floating around the web you're not
going to believe which icarly character
is the product of forbidden species love
watch until the end to find out who it
is
post radiation bikini bottom when you
look at the bizarreness of Bikini Bottom
and nickelodeon SpongeBob SquarePants it
raises some serious questions why does
the bottom of the sea look so weird
what's with the pineapple dwelling
kitchen sponge what kind of plants are
those and how did a squirrel with the
scuba suit get down there but hey just
listening to SpongeBob's laugh can make
anybody forget about physics right there
are countless memes floating around the
internet questioning this wackadoo
spongebob logic seriously how can a
whale be a daughter of a crab and what
is with all the underwater fires well
one theory may have the answer to all of
these burning questions see what we did
there this man believes that Bikini
Bottom is the site where dozens of
nuclear devices have been detonated
between the years 1946 and 1958 the real
name of this location is the Keeney
Atoll it's an Atoll in the Marshall
Islands so spongebob and his pals are
really a bunch of post radiation
creatures living in a mutated place
where underwater fires are a regular
occurrence when you consider the span
Theory everything makes total sense as
we all know from spider-man radiation
can turn seemingly impossible things
into reality meta Drake and Josh
fans have pointed out that Nickelodeon's
Drake and Josh takes place in the same
universe as iCarly Sam and cat and
victorious we'll get more into that
later but one fan blew everyone's mind
with this theory that takes Drake and
Josh to a whole new different level this
fan believes that Drake and Josh is
really a reality show within a show if
you're like us you might be saying wait
what this fan explains that the reason
every episode opens up with the main
characters speaking directly to the
camera is very similar to the office you
know when they are talking to the camera
about their experiences additionally
this fan pointed out an episode of
iCarly where the Drake & Josh TV show is
played on Carly's television
stunned him also the characters on
Victorious call off the show by name as
a TV show it happened on a TV show Drake
and Josh so by that logic Drake and Josh
must be a TV show in that combined
universe so Drake and Josh is actually a
show within a show otherwise who are
they talking to with these monologues it
only makes sense if they know that they
are on reality TV and are therefore
talking to their audience the secret
ingredient in Krabby Patties when you're
hungry for a burger in bikini bottom the
best place to go is the Krusty Krab all
the fish love to dine at this fast-food
establishment with a sponge for a cook
into cranky calamari for a cashier we
all know that plankton has been doing
everything in his power to get his hand
on the secret krabby patty recipe but
what could it be that makes these
burgers stay so good the answer may
freak you out
redditor milk lust pointed out a
disturbing fact about crabs the fact is
that many crustaceans are cannibals so
mr. Krabs is just doing what normal
crabs do when he serves up his relatives
on a bun with lettuce and tomatoes
according to Nick comm that secret
krabby patty formula
is loaded with imitation crab meat now
some may argue that imitation crabmeat
is not the same as actual crab meat we
have one response to this argument would
you eat anything that had the ingredient
imitation human mates we didn't think so
so not only is mr. Krabs greedy but he's
also scary if you happen to be a fellow
crustacean this theory is making fans
shudder every time they see a citizen of
Bikini Bottom ordering a krabby patty
Nickelodeon remakes there's an
interesting theory on reddit's that the
Nick shows from this decade are actually
remakes of old Nick shows from previous
generations I redditor who goes by the
handle the Northwest owner points out
some pretty undeniable similarities for
instance in 2012 there was a show on
Nickelodeon called Marvin Marvin
boy while the show wasn't on the air for
very long it was long enough for this
fan to draw this conclusion Marvin
Marvin could be a remake of the 90s Nick
show the journey of Alan strange this
fan points out that both shows are about
an alien teenage boy who lives with a
human family on earth then there is also
the show Nicky Ricky Dicky and Dawn this
astute snick theorist believes it's
actually a remake of a show from the
early 2000s their brothers Garcia both
shows are about siblings particularly
three brothers and a sister the final
example is the Nick show 100 things to
do before high school this show was also
short-lived however it's very possible
that it was a remake of the 2004 show
Ned's Declassified School Survival Guide
the northwestern compared the two shows
saying that both are about three friends
and their middle school adventures
coincidence are we make you be the judge
Danny Phantom is Timmy Turner this fan
theory has been around for a while it
states that Danny Phantom is really
Timmy Turner The Fairly OddParents and
Danny Phantom may appear to be wildly
different shows until you look deeper
nearly every character in Danny Phantom
bears a strong resemblance to the
characters on The Fairly OddParents they
just look like they've aged over time
Timmy and Danny have the same color eyes
the same hairdo and the same eyebrows
and the parents look alarmingly familiar
too when you think about it Sam could
just be an older Trudy Trixie as a
younger version of Paulina and Tuckers
is a more mature AJ maybe Timmy's final
wish before his 13th birthday was to be
a ghost hunting superhero he was
probably nervous about losing Cosmo and
Wanda forever with no one to protect him
it makes sense that he would want to be
someone else so Timmy gets a whole new
life as Danny Phantom and he gets to
keep his connections with older wiser
versions of his friends and family
that's a pretty clever take on these two
shows spongebob is a war veteran in the
Nickelodeon fan verse Spongebob
Squarepants theories are plentiful so
here's another fascinating one from the
theory playground that is reddit user
little Tony considers himself a loyal
fan of the popular Nickelodeon show this
fan believes that the fry cook we all
know and love is not this fun she claims
to be
to quote little Tony mr. Squarepants is
an ex-military soldier who is
freeing from post-traumatic stress
disorder or PTSD for short he was
discharged because of his shell-shocked
state so he retreated to bikini bottom
to try to have a normal life as a fry
cook according to little Tony there is a
lot of evidence to back up this theory
first Sponge Bob always dresses the same
everyday his Squarepants are like a
soldier's uniform he keeps it pressed
and neat at all times he has the exact
same morning routine every single day
and he needs a super loud horn to wake
him up since he is used to sleeping in
war zones this fan also believes that
Sponge Bob his military background is
the reason he says things like I aye-aye
captain and this theory is pretty dark
for a kids cartoon but it's definitely
interesting icarly is connected to
everything remember when we said we'd
circle back to the theory that icarly is
connected to everything in the nick
verse well here's a theory that lays it
all out as we stated before most people
know that there is a lot of
interconnectivity between all of the
next shows that aired around the same
time as iCarly many characters have
crossed over and appeared on each other
shows take the crossover episode between
icarly and victorious for example Drake
Bell also appeared on victorious and
characters from Drake and Josh appeared
on zoey 101 but you can go even further
down this rabbit hole the main
characters from Sam and cat come from
icarly and victorious then this fan
recalls when Drake from Drake and Josh
showed up on an episode of game shakers
then Henry hearts from Henry danger
appeared on game shakers in addition the
episode of the thundermans titled danger
and thunder connects these two shows as
well and lastly in Drake and Josh
addy senior from unfabulous meets up
with Megan so that puts iCarly in
connection with victorious Drake and
Josh
Sam and cat Zoey 101 unfabulous game
shakers Henry danger and the thundermans
they're all together in the same realm
kind of mind-blowing right Imaginary
Friends there have been many articles
written about this Rugrats theory
pre-warning it's a real tearjerker
so apparently since Angelica is
considered a spoiled sad and lonely
child
- such a bad thing why whose workaholic
mother neglects her she made up some
imaginary friends that's right all the
babies in Nickelodeon's Rugrats are made
up figments of Angelica's imagination
she needed someone to play with so she
used her creativity to deal with her
loneliness now there is some debate as
to whether the baby's ever actually
existed one theory is that they did
exist at one time but then fell victim
to some pretty terrible tragedies
another theory is that Angelica did what
many only children do she simply made up
friends to play with and she made them
babies so that she could be in control
and be the boss many kids make up fake
brothers sisters friends are even
imaginary babies of their own it's not
uncommon at all but this does kick us in
the fields a little bit poor Angelica
was just a lonely child with no one to
play with she provided companionship for
herself or rather she created it out of
thin air good for her every kid deserves
a playmate The Adventures of Pete and
Pete this Nickelodeon show was about two
redheaded brothers with the same name
Pete and Pete's The Adventures of Pete &
Pete followed the siblings through many
funny and wild moments in the town of
Wellsville while it was a children's TV
series it alluded to many adult themes
their portrayal of typical everyday
suburban life has been called abstract
and even absurd at times the show was
loaded with obscure cultural references
such as Citizen Kane
[Music]
Jimmy Hoffa in the classic 80s movie
Ferris Bueller's Day Off while the show
only aired for three seasons it has
remained a pretty unforgettable part of
Nickelodeon's past that makes for some
interesting show theories the most
shocking theory was that big Pete
actually had schizophrenia this means
that little Pete and Artie are
hallucinations based on the delusions of
a mentally ill person fans pointed out
that Pete's mom or dad never really
talked to one Pete about the other one
fan recalled that in the second season
already saw that little Pete was facing
his bullies all on his own this could be
a sign that little Pete was big Pete
hallucinating a time when he stood up
for himself and didn't need Artie to
save him son of a B this crazy icarly
fan Theory has to do with a woman of B
and a boy named Freddie one fan of the
show took to Twitter to post this
bizarre theory this fan believes that
Freddie Benson's mother was the
character in the B movie who got
together with the B from the film Barry
B Benson together they created Freddie
Benson from icarly this resulted in a
total retweet storm fans recalled that
mrs. Benson is constantly worried about
protecting Freddie
in fact she's a total helicopter parent
according to this B theorist her anxiety
stems from her accidentally squashing
very she doesn't want Freddie to meet
the same demise even if he has a human
child and that a flying insect this
theory may seem absolutely bonkers
however the actor who played Freddie
Benson in the show actually confirmed it
on Twitter he responded to a fan theory
saying that someone finally figured it
out who knew a boy could be the son of a
woman and a bee while this clearly makes
no sense it's fun to speculate after all
that's what fan theories are all about
before you go tell us which fan theory
was your favorite in the comments
section below and while you're at it
tell us if you have any absurd
Nickelodeon fan theories of your own
give this video a big thumbs up if you
love Nickelodeon shows for more
mind-blowing theories subscribe to the
things thanks for watching we'll see you
soon
[Music]